she just basically had a lot of the
green flag the reason we broke up was
because she moved to another state i
just don't really know if i've ever find
a girl with so many of the green flags
that she had you know because we talk
about there's eight billion people on a
planet half of them are women it's
arrogant to think that there's nobody
that's going to be better than she is
why would you subscribe to any notion
that doesn't serve what's best for you
right no that's true having an unhealthy
attachment to a girl that's not even in
your life anymore and thinking
is there going to be anyone better than
that that belief does not serve you kill
it i guess it's done imagine that you
get so good at game at making money
you're captivating you're not a boring
guy you know you take care of yourself
and then
she sees you know this new version of
you with women around you imagine you
know she now wants to move back to
california to be with you thinking how
stupid she was and at that point in time
you might even have a better girl and
you're going to say you know what lost
your chance babe sorry
yeah i appreciate everything rich thank
you for everything you do thanks